[موسيقى]
يقولوا الاديب والمؤرخ البريطاني الشهير
الذي عاش في القرن الثامن عشر في الاسلام
خله موده اراها من اشرف الخلال واجلها وهي
تسويه بين الناس فالناس في الاسلام سواء
والاسلام لا يكتفي بجعل الصدقه سنه محبوبه
بل يجعلها فرضا على كل مسلم مقتدر وقاعده
من قواعد الاسلام
يقصد توماس الزكاه ويتابع
هذه الصدقات للفقراء والمساكين والمنكوبين
جميل والله كل هذا وما هو الا صوت
الانسانيه صوت الرحمه والاخاء والمساواه
يصيح من فؤاد ذلك الرجل محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم ابن القطار والصحراء
لو عدد توماس كارليل الى يومنا هذا لما
غير رايه فدعون من حكايه جلد الذات حين
نتحدث عن الامه وشعوبها فالخير باق فيها
حتى تفنى الارض الى العناوين
اطفال سوريا ارهقهم التهجير وحولهم الى
باعه متجولين
في افغانستان يبيع ابنه لكي يطعم اطفاله
عراقيون يقتاتون من النفايات على بعد
امتار من الثروه
سودانيون وقعوا عقود عمل في الامارات
فوجدوا انفسهم يقاتلون في ليبيا
ذهب لتفجير مسجد فصار امامه وتحول الى
داعيه اسلاميه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا واهلا بكم الى هذه الحلقه الخاصه من
الامثال الشاميه عصفور وغط على بيضه يقال
للاشاره الى ان الرزق الوفير لن تؤثر
عليها العطايا القليله فالبيدر وهو
الموضوع الذي يجمع فيه القمح في القرى لن
ينقص من الحبات التي تاكلها العصافير
مبدا يطبقه حرفيا صاحب متجر تركي اعتادت
الطيور في السوق على التردد عليه وهو سعيد
لاخذ وجباتها اليوميه من اصناف الحبوب
المعروضه ثروه بعض الاغنياء وحاجات بعض
الفقراء تتشابه مع السهول والبيادر في
مقابل حبيبات قمح العصافير كتلك الطفله
السوريه كوثر التي تحلب بالعوده الى
المدرسه ليس الى المدرسه السويسريه
الاغلى في العالم من حيث مصاريف السنه
الدراسيه بل الى اي مدرسه مجانيه لابناء
الفقراء لكن الطفله تعمل وقد تعبت من
العمل بياعه لاغراض الاطفال في الشوارع
فالاحوال صعبه تقول هاي كنت في المدرسه صح
بس هلا بطلت
الامور صعبه
[موسيقى]
وهذا وعد مني
احتجاز الولايات المتحده بعض اموال الدوله
الافغانيه لا يرسل الاباء ابناءهم للعمل
على قولهم لبيع الطفل من اجل انقاذ بقيه
افراد الاسره لا احد يريد ان يشاهد كل
التقرير سنكتفي بعرض افاده احد الاباء
في مدينه اخن الالمانيه عائله تركيه لا
تشكو من ضيق الحال بل من مفاجات الغربه
الصادمه لقد صادرت السلطات الرضيعه بعد
اتهام امه بانها مطربه نفسيه منعوها من
ارضاعه لم يسلموه لعائله تركيه اخرى بل
ذكرن مثليين الطفل اسمه امير وهو الان
اسير بحسب العائله
برج اليوم
فيما البحث
اطفال
او الوحيده التي غادرت بحث عن مكان ترغب
فيه الامن والرعايه الصحيه والانسانيه
سبقهم في ذلك ليبيون اخرون
نحو اوروبا
مهاجرين غير قانونيين في البحر وبعضهم يتم
رميهم وصفادير ايديه هذا الاتهام قد لا
تهضمه جهات اوروبيه
وتعتبرهم مسيسا لكن ماذا عن شهاده منقذ
يوناني في ممارسات خطر السواحل في بلاده
هل تستحق تحقيقا اوروبيا يقول المنقذ ان
خفر السواحل اليوناني يحتجز اللاجئين
الذين يصلون الى الشواطئ اليونانيه يقودهم
الى اماكن سريه يصادرها هواتفهم وجوازات
سفرهم ثم يرميهم في المياه الدوليه مجددا
ويضيف لدينا خبر السواحل الوحيد في العالم
الذي يرمي المهاجرين في البحر بدلا من
انقاذهم ولا يقدموا لهم الطعام والماء او
وسائل الانقاذ من الغرق المحتوم فرنسا لا
ترفض دخول اللاجئين اليها فحاسم
يمنع دخول ناشطه حقوقيه لانها تناهض
الوجود الفرنسيه الاستعماري في افريقيا
سيده سوتشي او نتالي اسم يرتبط بنظام
امراه انتفضت بوجه فرنسا الاستعماريه
واتخذت من المناظر الدوليه والعالميه منصه
لمسانده القضايا الافريقيه الناشطه
الحقوقيه نتالي السويسريه الكاميرونيه
لطالما كانت محله ملاحقه ومضايقه من قبل
السلطات الفرنسيه اخرها قرار وزاره
الداخليه الفرنسيه بمنعها دخول الاراضي
الفرنسيه بتهمه التحريض واستخدام العنف
نتالي واحده من بين الالاف الذين قوموا
قصد اسكات صوتهم لرغبتهم في فرنسا عن
العباءه الاستعماريه الفرنسيه
اما في البصره فامتار قليله تفصل بين
ثروات العراق الباطنيه ومكبات النفايات
التي تعطش عائلات عليها في ظل حكم احزاب
الشعارات الثوريه الكبيره
النفايات لا يفصلهم عن الحقول النفطيه في
مدينتهم سوى بضع امتار
الدوله
لا يفصلهم عن الحقول النفطي
هؤلاء العائلات ومنذ سنوات خارج الحسابات
الحكوميه عائلات لبنانيه لم يعد بمقدورها
الى محلات السوبر ماركت فالصغير لا يفهموا
التحولات الكارثيه التي طرات على حياته
دمرتنا الحياه الفرقه الارض دمرنا اكتر
[موسيقى]
انا اسمي جوال بشوي عندي اربع اولاد
الكبير عمره عشر سنين والصغير عمره ثلاث
سنين وخاف عليه يعني ما يكبروا ما يطولوا
يكون عنده سوء تخزين وما عم بيقدروا
ياكلوا لا لحمه لا دجاج لفويكه وجوزك كله
لو يقبضن مليونين الموتور وين الكهرباء
يعني في اوقات بننزل على السوبر ماركت ما
بنقدر ننزله اولادنا لانه اذا استحله شيء
ما فيك تقولي لهم بعدين يمكن اول الشهر
[موسيقى]
لا انا وصلنا تحت عنوان تجاره رقيق في
الزمن الحديث تكشف قناه الحره قصص
سودانيين دفعتهم الحاجه لتوقيع عقود عمل
في الامارات لصالح الشركات الامنيه
التقليديه التي تخدم عاده المتاجر الكبرى
ومسابح يجد انفسهم بدون مقدمات على خطوط
النار والقتل في ليبيا لصالح حلفاء
الامارات وقوات حفتر
طبيعي جدا جدا
العمل داخل الامارات
[موسيقى]
اقدامهم عندما يمشون على الطرقات لا سيما
في الرياء فالالغام الارضيه ملاحق مفتوحه
لحرب لم تنتهي بعد مكتبه برنامج الامم
المتحده لتنسيق الشؤون الانسانيه يقول ان
نصف سكان سوريا معرضون لخطر المتفجرات وان
نحو 50% من المقيمين داخل سوريا مهددون
بالتعرض الانفجار ما يقارب ثلاث مئه الف
ذخيره متفجره في الانفجار خلال الحرب التي
استمرت 11 عاما وان هذه الالغامه ما تزال
كامله ولم تنفجر يدعي الاعلامه الاسرائيلي
تسجيل ت في طلبات الحصول على الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه في صفوف السوريين الدروز من
الجولان ويضيفوا الاعلام العبري ان
المتقدمين بالطلبات يفعلون ذلك للهروب من
حكم النظام السوري في مجدل شمس والقرى
الدرزيه الثلاث الاخرى بقعاتها ومسعه
وعينقينيا يقتل واكثر من 22 الف سوري نحو
اربعه الاف منهم يحملون الجنسيه
الاسرائيليه رجال الدين في الجولان فرضوا
الحرمان الدينيه والمقاطعه الاجتماعيه على
كل من يحصل على الجنسيه الاسرائيليه
معطيات جديده كشفت النقابه عن ارتفاع
طلبات الحصول على الجنسيه الاسرائيليه لدى
السكان السوريين هنا في قرى الجولان خلال
العامين مواطنون في الجولان ذكروا ان
مساله معارضه وتاييد الرئيس السوري بشار
الاسد كانت احدى العوامل التي دفعت البعض
لحمل وطالب الجنسيه الاسرائيليه تحضير
للاصدقاء المشاهدين من مشاهد مقرفه في
التقرير التالي من الاعلام العبري والذي
يتحدث عن القذاره التي يخلفها السياح
الاسرائيليون في اوروبا
شرقا لطالما اشتكت منهم بعض فنادق دبي
التي اصبحت بحاجه الى اعمال صيانه وتنظيف
كوميين دخول
[موسيقى]
الخدمه
هو ما يعيق السياحه في مصر بل مشكله مشاكل
السياحه بحسب همزه عين هي اذان صلاه
المسلمين والادين على الهواء مباشره
شغال جوه الفندق
تيجي تتكلم وتقول يا جماعه ده كلام
عشان خاطر السياحه
في القران والسنه بدل ان يعالج الطبيب
المريض اخذ منه العدوى وصار مريضين بحاجه
للعلاج كذلك الحركه الاسلاميه
التي اخذت جزءا من شرعيتها الشعبيه من
معارضتها استبداد بعض الحكام هي شابهت
الحكام في الكثير من ادائها والكلام
للداعيه محمد الصغير الذي يعرف عن نفسه
بانه ابن الحركه الاسلاميه
على الشعوب الحركه الاسلاميه لا ترحب
بالعلماء في داخلها قد يختلف معك كثيرون
لكن ابن الحركه الاسلاميه
العلماء الذين لهم استقلاليه داخل الحركه
الاسلاميه غير مرحب بها الحركه الاسلاميه
جندي سابق في البحريه الامريكيه نشا على
كراهيه الاسلام اثناء قتاله في غزو العراق
وافغانستان
وعندما علم بوجود تلامذه المسلمين مع
ابنته بالمدرسه استشاط غضبا وقررت تفجير
مركز ومسجد اسلامي لدفع المسلمين الى
الهجره
[موسيقى]
ريتشارد لم يفجر فما الذي جعله يغير خطته
لدى وصوله الى المركز الاسلامي وكيف اصبح
رئيسا للمركز الاسلامي الذي ذهب لتفجيره
وقت لمنفيه
[موسيقى]
نسال عني دبل موسم
السجين الذي كان الاكثر كلفه قبل ان يفرج
عنه على اليمين المتشدد في الولايات
المتحده هو ياسر البحري سجين كويتي سجن
ظلما في الولايات المتحده بحسب التقرير
وقد اسلم على يده 500 سجين امريكي
سافر الى امريكا في عام 2001 بغرض الدراسه
وهناك اسس عده اعمال الناجحه منها مقها
اصبح الاهم في ولايه فلوريدا في عام 2007
بالتحرش بفتاه تعمل بالمقهى رغم ان ياسر
اكد على براءته وقدم الادله للمحكمه لكن
هيئه المحلفين حكمت عليه بالسجن لمده 15
عام تنقل فيها بين سبعه سجون وتعلم عده
لغات بالاضافه لتاليفه عشرات الكتب والا
ومن ذلك كله هو اسلام 500 شخص على يده كما
انشا اربع مكتبات اسلاميه في سجون مختلفه
[موسيقى]
في المتفرقات وفي بدايات انتشار وباء قبض
19 قدرت وكاله بلومبرج اضرار الاقتصاد
الامريكي بانه يعادل الضعف ما انفقته
واشنطن على الحروب في افغانستان والعراق
وسوريا مشكله جديده تطرق باب خزائن
الولايات المتحده وهذه المره على شكل حشره
تهدد المحاصيل الزراعيه اسمها الفانوس
المرقق وما يجمعها بكرونا هو انهما من
منشا واحد من الصين وفق قول الامريكيين
اذا رايتها اقتلها في الحالي ومن دون تردد
حمله اطلقها خبراء البيئه للقضاء على حشره
الفانوس المرققه الاولى على قائمه
المطلوبين وذلك لانها ستكلف الاقتصاد
الامريكي ما يزيد عن 500 مليون دولار
بلواه تمثل ايضا تهديدا لاكثر من سبعين
نوعا من النباتات صار الغذاء والامريكي في
خطر وتعود اصولها الى اجزاء من القاره
الاسيويه لكن يرجح موقع بويجين يسري بورد
ان حشره الفانوس المرققه قد دخلت الولايات
المتحده عن طريق سفن ووسائل الشحن القادمه
من الصين تحديدا حصل توماسكو من جنوب
افريقيا على لقب اغبى مجرم بعد دخوله
المغفره للشرطه لتقديم طلب للحصول على
وظيفه برغم ان نسمه كان مدرجا على قوائم
المطلوبين وقد ضلت توماس هاربا على مدار
سبع سنوات ثم دخل مركز الشرطه على قدميه
فصدت يده توما ظل هاربا على مدار سبع
سنوات بعد سرقه اجهزه كهربائيه بقيمه
1200$ وارسالها الى عناوين اخرى اثناء
عمله بالتوصيل ومعجز السلطاته في القبض
عليه قادته قدمه الى مركز الشرطه ليشتكي
من تاخر الرد على طلبه في الحصول على
وظيفه في كذا الا ان احد افراد الشرطه
تمكن من معرفته والقبض عليه تعلم العربيه
ولو كنت من الصين حكمه صحفي صيني يلقي
ابياتا من شعر ابي الطيب المتنبي كما لا
يجيد ذلك الكثير من العرب المعاصرين بما
تعلل لا اهل ولا وطنه
ولا نديم ولا كاس ولا سكن
اريد من زمني ذا ان يبلغني ما ليس يبلغه
من نفسه الزمن ما كل ما يتمنى المرء يدركه
تجري الرياح بما لا تشتهي السفن
والسلام عليكم اخيرا اختارت المانيا
الحمار ليكون الحيوان الاليف في عام 2022
وكشفت دراسه علميه حديثه ان الانسان قد
روض الحمير منذ سبعه الاف عام لكن من ينكر
ان الحمير في بعض الاماكن والاوقات قد اكل
اليها ترويض البشر في المانيا مثلا اختير
الحمار الحيوان الاليف لسنه 2022 افضل
حيوان اليف لهذا العام متفوقا على الكلاب
والقطط مثلا واخر تلك الدراسات حول الحمار
نشرت هذا الشهر في مجله ساينس العلميه
العريقه واهتمت هذه الدراسه بتاريخ تدجين
او ترويض الحمير ان تدجين او ترويض الحمار
من طرف الانسان قديم جدا يعود لسبعه الاف
عام
[موسيقى]
ختاما دخل كلب ذات يوم الى مصنع للمرايا
التي تحيط بالجدران من كل جانب
بمجرد الراء انعكساته على هذه المرايا صدم
الكلب من رؤيته قطيعا من الكلاب امامه ومن
خلفه وعلى اليمينه
كشر عن انيابه وبدا بالنباح لترد عليه
الكلاب الاخرى التي لم تكن سوا انعكاسا له
ولحركاته واصل النفحه بقوه وراحه يقفز
ذهابا وجيء وحاولا يخافه الكلاب المحيطه
به التي تطابقت حركاتها معه وهكذا استمر
الكلب المظلوم دون جدوى حتى صباح اليوم
التالي حيث عثر عليه حارس المصنع جيفه
هامده
لم يكن هناك احد لايذاء الكلب في المصنع
لكنه قتل نفسه بنفسه بسبب عراقي مع
انعكاساته الوهميه
قد يتعب قلبك اهم ثقيل وقلق من التربص بك
وغالبا لا احد يتربص بك اكثر من نفسك
فارحمها الى اللقاء
مستودع
الاسرار يا
موجبون كم مقله
خافتنا تهتير الظلام
المستانين
حسيبته اشباح
انوار راحت
ترتجيل فيه المعين لم يدري ان الفجر
يطرده امام
[موسيقى]
ناظري